ｹﾞﾎｯ
ｹﾞﾎｯｹﾞﾎｯ
語り）皆さんは
語り）風邪を引いたことはあるだろうか･･･
語り）風邪を引いた自分とは別に
語り）体は元気だが
語り）心が動かない･･･
う”う”ぇ”ぇ
ｳｳ(高音)
ｳｳ～（高音）
語り）そういった経験のある人もいるだろう･･･
ｳ"ｴ”ｯﾎ
語り）心と体のバランスが取れていない状態である･･･
語り）そんな状態の
語り）1人の男のお話である･･･
ｳｯﾎｳｯﾎ(咳)
ｹﾞﾎｯ
は）おい、みんな大丈夫か
右腕）俺は大丈夫だ！
右腕）左腕！お前は?
左腕）なんとか無事だ･･･
左腕）血圧も安定している･･･
右足）俺様はピンピンしてるぜっ！
右足）なぁ！相棒よ！
左足）当たり前だ。
左足）貴様
左足）誰に口を利いている!!(おこ)
は）よかった･･･他のみんなは?
心臓）咳によるダメージがありますが
心臓）なんとか無事です
心臓）ご心配ありがとうございます、隊長
は）気にするな
は）お前がやられては俺たちは全滅だ
は）今後ともよろしく頼むぞ･･･
心臓）了解です！
は）司令部！無事か?
脳）くっ･･･
脳）熱によるダメージで正常な判断が
できないかもしれない･･･
脳）すまない、はじめ･･･
ｹﾞﾎｯｹﾞﾎｯ
は）大丈夫か!!
は）みんなの無事が確認でき次第、すぐ休ませるから
は）もう少し頑張ってくれ･･･!
脳）ありがとう･･･
脳）よろしく頼んだ･･･
左足）かゆい･･･
左足）左腕･･･頼んだ！
左腕）仕方ねぇな･･･
左腕）どうだ?
左足）ふぅ･･･
左足）生き返るぜ･･･
右腕）はじめ！
は）どうした?
右腕）みんな何とか無事なようだが、どうする?
は）そうだな･･･
は）ひとまずみんなの確認が取れたが
は）脳だけがまだ状態が良くない･･･
は）1回全員休んで、あいつを休ませる必要がある
???）ﾀｽｹﾃｴ~
は）誰だっ?!
耳）んっ?
右腕）んんっ?
右足）ん？　左足）ん？
???）ﾀｽｹﾃｴ~
は）こっ、この声は･･･
???）喉が乾いたよぉ~(小声)
右腕）おいっ！
右腕）この声は間違いねぇ！　???）水分が飲みたいよぉ~
は）あぁ。
???）誰かっ、誰かたすけてぇ~(小声)
は）喉だ。
心臓）どうやら
心臓）喉が乾いているようですね･･･
は）くそっ!!
は）完全に盲点だった･･･
左足）おいっ！
は）んっ?
右足）俺たちが力を合わせて
右足）あいつを助けるしかねぇだろう！
左足）そうだ
左足）俺たちならいける･･･
は）でも･･･脳が･･･！
心臓）そうだよっ！
心臓）ここで無理したら脳がっ･･･！
脳）俺の･･･ことは･･･
脳）大丈夫だ･･･（弱々しい声）
は）脳！
右腕・ｼｬﾝｯ☆（鈴の音）
左腕・ｼｬﾝｯ☆（鈴の音）
右足・ｼｬﾝｯ☆（鈴の音）
左足・ｼｬﾝｯ☆（鈴の音）
脳）俺のことは･･･大丈夫だから･･･
脳）早くっ、水を･･･
脳）ｸﾞｱﾍｯｯ（倒れる）
心臓）脳さんっ！！
心臓）無茶しないでっ！！
右腕）見ろよっ！
右腕）脳はもう限界だっ！
右足）だからって喉を見捨てるっていうのかっ！
右足）これはっ！
右足）俺たちの命にも関わるんだぞっ！
心臓）脳のことも考えてくださいよっ！
心臓）無茶ですよ、今はっ！
左足）ｱ”ｱ"ﾝｯ??
左足）やんのかっ??!（げきおこ）
右足）俺たちならコンビニまで行けるんだよっ！
右足）俺たちがやらなきゃっ！
右腕）それが無理っつってんだろっ!!（激おこぷんぷん丸）
右足）じゃあなんとかしてくれよっ！（激おこ）
右腕）それなら俺たちが行くっ！
右腕・左腕）逆立ちでいってやんよ！！
左足）馬鹿かっ！（おこ）
左足）頭に血が上って余計危ねーわっ！（激おこ）
左足）あほっ！！！（激おこ）
は）もういい！
は）みんなやめてくれーっ！！(叫)
は）俺は
は）俺はみんなを救いたい･･･
は）ここで水を取りに行かなければ
は）喉がやられちまう･･･
は）だが･･･
は）これ以上この体で移動すると
は）脳がどうなるかわからねぇ･･･
心臓）僕たちは･･･
心臓）どうすれば･･･
は）みんな･･･
は）大丈夫だ
は）大丈夫･･･
脳）そうだ･･･（か弱い声）
脳）俺のことは気にせず･･･
脳）早く･･･
脳）喉に･･･
脳）水を･･･
脳）ｷﾞｮﾍｴｴｴｯ
は･右腕･左腕･右足･左足）脳ーーーーーーっ！！
右腕）はじめっ！！
ﾊﾞﾁﾝｯ☆(BI☆N☆TA☆)
右腕）お前が決めるんだ･･･
右腕）俺たちは･･･
右腕）お前に従う･･･
は）ありがとう･･･
は）右腕･･･
右腕）ｸﾞｯｯｯｯｯ!!!
は）急ぐぞみんなっ！！！！
は）脳のためにもっ！！
は）喉のためにもっ！！
は）みんなで力を合わせて
は）コンビニに行って、
は）水を買いに行くしか
後輩）はじめさん何か要ります～？？
は）あっ、水もらっていい～？
♪エンディング♪